from our i-team amari nicholson is the
name many of our viewers know by now and
according to testimony in the newly
released court documents
the toddler's accused killer drew a map
for police after he confessed
vanessa murphy joins us live in studio
to explain more about the alleged
confession vanessa
yeah police say once terrell rhodes knew
he was caught in a lie he changed his
story and then confessed
to killing amari nicholson omari was
just two years old
i want to warn our viewers the details
here are tough to listen to
during an interview with police a
homicide detective
testified in front of the grand jury
that rhodes quote admitted that amari
had
urinated on himself several times and he
became upset
and angry so he hit amari several times
and quote
he explained amari was gasping for air
and then turned blue and purple
in the face he said he tried cpr and
amari could not be revived
rhodes was watching amari while his
girlfriend who is the child's mother was
out of town to help care for a family
member police say rhodes drew a map to
show where he put amari's body
investigators found the child's remains
the next day
i talked with amari's mother last month
he took a precious child away from many
people
and he needs to pay attention to how we
all feel because this is not okay
we do not know at this point whether the
clark county district attorney's office
will pursue the death penalty
last month d.a steve wolfson told me it
was
too early to tell rhodes is currently at
the clark county detention center facing
charges for murder
attempted murder assault on a protected
person and
resisting an officer those charges are
related to roads
grabbing an officer's gun in the
interview room
more on that at five and six back to you